well I'd like to thank you for joining
me on this uh broadcast uh talking about
the potential of robots as a Next
Generation technology for clinical
assessment of neurological disorders
to begin
I like to uh make a couple uh comments
and this is just what I like to call
affectionately why you might ignore this
talk first I'm a basic scientist and I'm
new to clinical research the second is
I'm co-founder and CSO of Beacon
Technologies the commercializes the
robots for basic and clinical research
so I have a clear conflict of interest
however I think both these aspects help
me with the problem of what's called
knowledge translation valleys of death
and that I hope that being a basic
scientist it will help take and
translate the ideas of using robots from
basic biomedical research to clinical
research and get through the valley of
death one
and involved in commercialization is
what I consider essential if we're going
to ever get through the valley of death
too which is from Clinical Research to
changing clinical practice
so what is the question I want to try to
address with robots well it's a problem
of assessment because it drives the
Health Care system
to Sydney Crosby who's shown on the left
have a concussion
at what point is he able to go back to
play
if you think about a drug
what is the right Therapeutics does the
drug work and is how is it effective and
finally if someone say has a stroke like
in the bottom right diagram what is the
biggest problem they have is strength
really the problem or should we be
addressing something else and that's all
driven by the assessment
now clinical assessment for brain
function
is traditionally done with rather simple
tasks such as touch nose and finger and
you score it out of zero one or two and
there's several basic problems with this
not most obvious is it's subjective it's
based on visual physical inspection by
the clinician
and by doing that you have to have core
scales zero one or two and that allows
it to be consistent across clinicians
but it's very hard to show Improvement
when you have such a course rating
system
the other problem is you get fluorine
ceiling effects with many of these uh
techniques whether it's a floor because
you get a zero but clearly there's
different levels of impairment or people
could get a full score of two but still
have some sort of impairments that are
different from healthy controls the
other challenge is many of these take to
cover all of the different aspects of
brain function they're very time
consuming and in many situations they
don't necessarily always practice and
performed
so the overview is to try to persuade
you about the potential of robots for
neurological assessment I'm going to go
through and illustrate how we've been
using robots for assessing sensory motor
and cognitive functions subject to
stroke and then I'll finish with some
future directions we see uh that are you
will be taking the technology
now basic research has been using robots
for many many years so the diagrams on
the left show some very various examples
of robots that are exist and are
available today and that are used to
study basic motor control and motor
learning the diagram on the right is
just to illustrate the broad circuits
that are involved in this and we've made
a lot of Headway in trying to understand
how different areas of the brain
cerebellum primary motor cortex provides
specific information and in their
involvement in control and learning
basic premise for thinking about
clinical assessment is can we do the
reverse process if it's useful for basic
research on the brain why not clinical
applications so in my regular day job I
like to call it I often try to
understand non-human primates and
neurophysiology about what neural
activities related in different brain
regions I have an area like primota
cortex I'm interested in understanding
its involvement in control I build tasks
I use the robot I quantify behavior and
from that try to identify based on the
neural activity patterns what is the
function of pre-motor Cortex
and the idea is to do the same sort of
principle with clinical assessment you
have a patient there's something wrong
with her brain we can take that subject
put them into a robotic device quantify
their behavior through a range of
different tasks and from there identify
what is the brain dysfunction
why robots for neurological assessment
well they're inherently objective you
can quantify limb movement with the
robots and you can also control the
movements precisely
they're easily combined with virtual
reality to simulate complex scenarios
and importantly they can automate tasks
and analyzes
why the Upper Limb well you can do a
broad range of voluntary motor actions
with your arms it's easy to quantify
whole limb movements we have a very
distributed Network for involving Upper
Limb perception in action and so you can
tap a large quantity of the brain
circuits
and we can take advantage of the large
body of research we only have developed
on basic research of Upper Limb motive
function for these developments clinical
tools and finally we can also use the
arm as basically a readout of any
cognitive processes we're interested in
so here's a video that will be displayed
and it's just showing uh the basic
design of the Ken arm exoskeleton robot
it's um an excess exoskeleton robot I'm
not sure if it's displaying yet
but basically it's showing a robot that
we have at St Mary's of the Lake
Hospital it's a local hospital in
Kingston where we have set up uh the
robot
and uh we set the subject up
and the subjects are adjusted by uh to
adjust the shape of the robot the
subjects uh adjust can move their arms
in the horizontal plane moving shoulder
and elbow movements and then they can be
wheeled into a virtual reality system so
they look down and can see virtual
targets displayed uh in the horizontal
plane I can't see the video so I'm not
quite sure where we are at in it the
diagrams showing a very simple task
visual guided reaching where central
Target turns on and the subject simply
reach out to the Target as it's
displayed in the same workspace as the
limb the diagram also
shows or the video also shows the basic
operating system where the operator can
watch and monitor how the subject's
Performing the task
so that's the that video I'd like to now
just skip quickly to a little bit a
second video
which is going to show a reaching video
um so this is a basic data of a healthy
control subject performing reaching
movements and a subject with stroke and
the subject on the left is the control
subject you'll see the move
quickly and accurately to the spatial
targets
and they make maybe one small corrective
movement but it's fairly simple to see
on the other side what you'll see is
um
stroke subject and they'll have lots of
problems moving their movements are
jerky they have large errors in trying
to reach and attain the goal they'll be
slow to move and so you can just
visually see the profound difference in
their performance between how a stroke
subject and a control subject so we'll
end that video and then go to some
now we go to the visual this is just an
example of the data that was displayed
here's a healthy control subject showing
Point by Point movement subject on the
stroke is on the right and again the
jerking movement's large variability
that is present
and from there we look at that raw data
and we can now start to calculate a wide
range of information about how they
perform so the diagram here is showing
12 different parameters that we can
quantify about reaching movements the
diagram is showing movements of a stroke
subject from the start to Central Target
to a peripheral Target you can show that
there's a large error at the beginning
there's lots of Wiggles of corrective
movements and we can quantify and
stratify lots of different features
about their motor performance on each
and every trial
some of the data one of the ones we
found very useful was the movement
Direction error so that first initial S
movement trying to go to the spatial
goal how far off in angular degrees
healthy controls are marked as circles
and the gray area is showing what's
healthy performance for the affected arm
and not affected alarm for strokes for
healthy controls it's simply the
dominant versus non-dominant and what
you can see is a small amount of error
about five degrees is normal for healthy
control and then the stroke subjects are
are marked as triangles either a
triangle pointing to the left is a left
affected stroke and triangles pointing
to the right is right affected strokes
and you can see that a large number of
them have large errors in their movement
directions
interestingly many of the left affected
subjects so they have strokes on the
right cerebral cortex actually have
impairments in both the affected and
non-affected arm and we actually found
uh almost half of the left affected
subjects had impairments bilaterally
another thing we can get with the data
is to actually compare between the two
limbs it turns out it's extremely
valuable for developing quantitative
tools is just to compare the two limbs
so this is looking at reaction time for
them to respond to the peripheral
targets uh the gray areas again the
healthy performance and what you can see
is the average time for movements for
both arms ranges from under 300
milliseconds to 500 milliseconds for
healthy controls there's a broad range
in healthy performance
so what's different is the difference in
the performance of the two Limbs and
that's on the y-axis that's the time
difference and what you can see is that
healthy subjects show very similar times
for both arms if they move quickly with
the right arm they will move quickly
with the left and slow they'll move with
both so the difference in the time is
only down to 50 milliseconds and that
allows us to identify subtle but
significantly impairments in very small
changes in reaction time between the two
limbs in some cases as small as 70
milliseconds we'll identify them as
having an impairment
this is an example of a subject that did
16 Targets this is some of our early
preliminary data and this is a chronic
stroke and this subject complained they
took his driver's license away and what
you can see is that while they had
troubles moving their poetic limb
um what you see is some targets actually
rarely moved at all and that would be to
the upper left quadrant and so this is a
very good reason why they lost their
license and you can see it quite quickly
here and that is that they just don't
respond to targets over on the left
field and so this is just another quick
example of how this type of Technology
easily quantifies these types of
impairments
the other value for this is to give
longitudinal analysis of performance
this is an example of a subject who the
clinical scores which we use the
shootout McMaster score were scores of
seven and seven for the left arm and
right you can see the Imperial where
it's three and two so that's a
substantial amount of impairment this is
assessments done four weeks after stroke
in five months in which you can see is
those scores are effectively the same
Shadow King Master is very similar to
the fugelmeyer for those that are
familiar with it so they didn't change
their clinical scores but if you look at
the right arm you will see that actually
their performance has improved to a
degree the movements are a little
straighter in the bottom panel for the
right arm and less variability so they
have still improved and were able to
quantify that
now moving on from motor skills we
wanted to look at other aspects of brain
processing and a particular area of
Interest was the area of somatosensation
and this is uh processed in parietal
lobe
and we use sensory information coming
from the limbs for doing things like
motor actions doing your buttons on your
shirt but it's also important for body
image to have awareness of where our
limbs are in space
and so we want to develop a task that
would address this so this is a video of
a matching task what it is going to show
is a healthy control subject where the
robot is going to move the right arm
into locations in the workspace and the
subject was instructed to move their
left arm to a mirror position so if the
arm goes out to the right they have to
the right arm then for the left arm they
have to move it out to the left
and this is to look at their ability to
know where their limb is in space
so we can move on from that slide and go
to
some of the data this is now just
showing that data for a healthy control
and sub stroke subject again robot move
the right arm what we've done is
positioned held up subject moved there
left arm which is their unaffected arm
for the stroke the black dots are
showing where they should have
positioned their hands uh the blue dots
and they're showing where they actually
positioned and this the ellipses are
showing the trial by trial variability
and what you can see is a profound
difference between the control subject
and subject uh subject with stroke
um healthy control shows small errors
and fairly small ellipses meaning fairly
good reproducibility of that spatial
location whereas the subject with stroke
had large variability denoted by the
large ellipse and large shift in the
workspace and so the next slide is just
going to show a couple more examples
two on the left are healthy control
subjects showing the types of
variability and errors that a normal
healthy subject would do in this task
and the other four are showing examples
of strokes and you can see very
different patterns of impairments from
some subjects showing very large
ellipses the top right panel where this
person's trial by trial variability is
enormous you can have systematic shifts
in the world which is shown in the
bottom right panel and you also can show
in the middle bottom panel an example of
how the world's actually shrunk
so these are all unique patterns that
can be observed in these subjects with
stroke
this is a control subject she's a lady
that was in her 80s
she passed all the traditional clinical
measures we collect a lot of healthy
control subjects to use as normative
data sets she performed this matching
task and the opened triangles and
objects are where they she should have
placed her hand the blue
um
icons are showing where she positioned
them and we'd never seen a healthy
control have this much of a shift in the
world we talked to her his physician she
had a CT scan and ended up having a
cerebellar infarct and a dural-based
tumor
so one thing we wanted to look at
because we're now thinking of using some
of these tasks for rehabilitation was
how much does vision Vision should
improve you would think this live
matching task and so what we did was We
performed this limb matching task with
and without Vision on the x-axis is
their performance without vision and on
the X Y axis is with vision what you can
see is these are all stroke subjects the
circles are those that fell within the
healthy range and you can see them
marked by the grayscale or better and
this is for systematic shift
what you can see is the subjects uh as
you would have probably guess is that
when you added Vision you would expect
them to improve their limb matching
capabilities and that's what all the
green icons are showing is those
subjects that had shift uh errors in the
position of the limb that improved when
they added Vision the unusual thing is
the red subjects or the red icons these
are subjects that actually had normal
limb matching capabilities normal
proprioception when they were given
Vision they actually created a
systematic shift and all of a sudden now
we're identified as impaired and I
suggests these are a very unique group
of subjects that actually have normal
proprioception when it's based on limb
afferent information but that this gets
distorted when vision is tried to
brought in with it which is an important
thing because it says these subjects
have a very more complex sensory motor
or multi-sensory integration problem
that's related to the visual integration
just to go across plus multiple tasks
and so the ideas here is looking at
performance of subjects across the
visual guided reaching task and the limb
matching task and what we found was if
you look at these subjects you can see
all possible combinations they're not
correlated between the sensory and motor
impairments some subjects are not
impaired in either some are impaired in
both but you could equally find subjects
that were impaired in only one task or
the other and these are the four example
subjects here where they have different
combinations of impairments so there's
no correlation between the impairments
in either task
but both of these tasks correlate with
the film score which is your measures of
daily activity suggesting that these
subjects do or this impairment in limp
position sense is impacting their
ability to do daily activities and
that's important to consider
sorry this diagram that I've missed up a
bit in exporting into PowerPoint but
this was some data where we're trying to
see if we could predict
future capabilities of stroke subjects
with various different markers and we
used a bit of a math mathematical model
called Fast orthogonal search and we
were trying to First predict both the
film intake score or the fim discharge
score and so what we did was for the
film intake we predicted using this math
model either using traditional clinical
measures like Shadow mcmaster's stroke
assessment scale Purdue pegboard
Modified Ashworth and see how well we
could predict and we also took our
reaching and matching tasks and looked
at how well we could predict you know it
turns out that actually the traditional
scores did a little bit better for
predicting the intake score
what was interesting was the fact that
for prognosis about where these subjects
are going to be at discharge from
Rehabilitation programs the robotic
measures actually gave a lot more
information uh in fact improved a lot
the ability to predict in fact there
they were significantly better than
either the traditional clinical measures
or in fact if you tried to predict based
on what their film intake score was
now clinical exams often have what I
call fairly simple
patterns of instructions like touching
your nose there's not a lot of
complexity but as the diagram on the
right shows when we act in the real
world it's a very complex environment
and so those are the things one has to
deal with if you're going to have people
be able to go back to do activities in
the real world
so we wanted to try to develop tasks
that we'd get at this problem of trying
to quantify more complex and Rapid motor
decisional processes so we came up with
this task which will be shown on the
video
that you will be clicked on here and
it's an object hitting task and what
this diagram is showing is
um
a three different subjects a healthy
control subject and two stroke subjects
what we've done is there's paddles
located at the hands of the subject and
they are instructed when the balls move
towards them in the workspace they are
to hit them away and you can actually
feel the balls they feel like little
squash balls as you push them away so
you get nice haptic feedback
and what you can see is the test starts
very easily so that we make sure all
subjects can hit
um some balls and therefore have no
floor effects but you'll see the task
will get more complicated uh with time
and all of a sudden there'll be more
balls falling they're going to move
quicker and all of a sudden it's
requiring the subjects to move
contactables more quickly and to manage
a lot of different decisional processes
not only about hitting a ball but
keeping track of other balls that are
acting in the environment
you can see the stroke subjects by now
show very profoundly different patterns
you have the stroke subject on the top
right you can see is what I call a
standard rational approach the subject
has an impairment on the right side on
their left arm they're going to use most
of the workspace to try to hit the balls
the subject on the bottom is a subject
of spatial neglect and you probably
should notice by now that they've
effectively ignored the entire left part
of the workspace their left arm is
impaired they rarely use it and the one
iron that could actually help them the
most is now squished over the right side
of the screen
and so you can just visually see a
profound difference in the three
different subjects here so we can close
that video and then I'll go and show a
visualization of the data from that task
this is object hit task uh and this is
now just showing the data the uh each
row there's 10 spots the balls were
falling the top row is showing the balls
that fell at the beginning when it was
really easy
and the bottom row is when the Falls
were falling very rapidly and what you
have is the left hand is blue if the
left hand hit it and red if the right
hand hit the ball and the black means
that the subject did not hit the ball at
all they missed the ball so the healthy
control subject is using the right hand
just a little bit more
that's because they were right-handed so
that tends to happen and you can see
that they have errors and they tend to
be focused on the most extreme left and
right sides because that's actually a
good choice when things get hard it
costs a lot to try to move that far out
far to the periphery so they tend to
make sure they focus on the ones in the
middle of the workspace
stroke subject number one you can see
that this subject missed a lot more
balls they're very asymmetric and
they're predominantly using the left
hand and the stroke subject too you can
see this
spatial neglect you can see that they're
hitting some balls in the left side of
the workspace just a few at the
beginning but then that seems to
diminish so as the task gets more
complicated they tend to focus even more
attention over to the right side and
ignore the left
and so about 85 percent of all stroke
subjects are identified as impaired in
this task the other good thing about
this task is it has a very good iterator
reliability where most of our parameters
stay above 0.9
we've also sort of pushed that type of
Paradigm further with trying to add
cognitive load and the idea is to stress
the brain and this is thinking about
areas like concussion where you are
trying to see if they can manage a large
volume of different complex situations
so in this case we simply ask that you
have to hit two objects and you must
avoid all the others and they perform
the same task and now they have to not
only worry about just hitting objects in
the environment they actually have to
handle attentional processes to decide
what is the object whether they should
hit it then as well as if it is an
object they're not supposed to hit they
have to avoid it in the workspace
we've also shown or the idea was to show
that you can take standard tasks like
Trail making and Port it onto a
computer-based environment and so we
have also done that just to illustrate
that you can put lots of different
existing tasks onto this platform and
the idea is to try to create One-Stop
shopping of having many different
sensory motor and cognitive processes
being assessed simultaneously
some of the future directions we're
going is to continue to expand the
capabilities and brain circuits that we
can assess with this technology the idea
is it's a general purpose platform so
this task here is called a ball on bar
task it's basically you have a bar that
connects the two hands you physically
feel the bar in the workspace and the
ball and the dot is on top of the white
dot and you simply are instructed to
move to the red dots in the workspace as
quickly and accurately as you can and
what we do is we change the complexity
of the task so at first the ball is
fixed next levels we have that if you
tilt the bar then it will roll and then
we finally allow the ball to roll and
make it more complex and the next video
is going to show you
um an example of a video of this task in
which a healthy control and stroke
subject are both trying to move in the
workspace with this ball rolling and you
can see the healthy control can move to
each of the locations fairly easily and
maintain balance on the with the ball
but the stroke subject by having
difficulty keeping their hands aligned
starts to have the ball roll and gets
into problems and So eventually the ball
starts to fall and roll off the
workspace
okay we can close that
and this is now just showing some data
on the types of information we can grab
from that we can get information on
global performance like how many targets
did they hit in a specified time in this
case they had a minute to do each level
and there's six levels
and we build a q sum curve of healthy
control so for level one healthy control
subjects will hit between 20 and 35
targets the red line is showing the
cumulative sum of all the stroke
subjects and you can see that 88 of the
stroke subjects could hit less than the
number observed for healthy controls
which is about 21. so that gives you
Global performance
we can also look at other aspects of
okay why are they failing and why are
they having problems to try to get into
the underlying uh deficits and
impairments in the brain one is just
simple uh how tilted is the bar when
they're trying to do this task you can
see that healthy controls the black line
is the cusum for healthy controls and
you can see that they have only a small
tilt less than five ten degrees whereas
the stroke subjects often have large
angles they can't keep the the bar
aligned in the horizontal plane or in
the coronal plane so 50 illustrate this
problem another is we can look at how
they're performing the task with the two
Limbs and this is uh shown on the hand
path length on the top right and
basically some subjects instead of
moving their hands the same amount they
will actually move one arm more than the
other to try to solve to move the bar
around in the workspace and so that's
shown on the panel on the right the
length of the bar is uh length of the
path is much different between the two
limbs
another task that we've got into and
again takes advantage of the ability of
the robot to apply perturbations in the
environment
um
and what you can see is we uh we'll go
to the next video this is to look at
really transcortical and spinal feedback
processes to see if they're intact so
the video is now going to show a control
subject the control subjects on the left
side of the video and the subject with
stroke is on the right side I missed
putting those labels on but you can see
there's a profound difference in the
performance of the subjects you see the
healthy control when this load is
applied by the robot it's a constant
load that comes on and all you have to
do is adjust your motor patterns to get
your hand back to the Target you can see
it does not disturb them very much
whereas the subject of stroke is very
delayed in making these corrective
responses and so you can see the very
large hand trajectories that pull the
hand away from the goal and it takes
them a lot longer to get back to the
central Target that they have to keep
their hand at that's the instruction
so for
um this data so if you close the video
we'll go to the next slide and what you
can see is the corrective responses for
these two different subjects and you can
see the small corrective rapid
corrective responses that are possible
by the healthy control in the top row so
that they uh quickly get back within a
few hundred milliseconds whereas the
subject with stroke will often show much
longer time periods to try to finally
counter the load and come back in this
case the subject was delayed and didn't
get back till 800 a thousand
milliseconds and the other excuse me
other interesting things is that often
we see bilateral problems with making
these corrective responses which is uh
I'll show in that slide after this this
slide here is simply showing the some
parameters that we extract for this task
deceleration time how long does it take
for them to try to stop and slow down
the arm from moving away as well as
endpoint error how far away were they
from the Target a central Target in this
task I should have mentioned they do not
have vision of the hand on most of the
trials so it's only using the math and
feedback so from this what you can see
is the data deceleration time is the
panel on the left all the small gray
circles and the bars are showing what
the healthy performance for control
subjects that we put through this task
as compared to age so healthy controls
always will
decelerate within 400 milliseconds and
you can see the stroke subjects that are
denoted by the triangles actually often
show much slower response times
panel on the right is the endpoint
errors and you can see that many of
these subjects keep their arms far far
away from the central Target they aren't
making corrective responses back to the
central goal
as I briefly mentioned what's
interesting is is that even though
stroke impacts one side uh one of the
two hemispheres we often found subjects
had bilateral impairments so these are
just showing examples of data for the
non-dominant or affected arm and that's
on the x-axis and we then have the
unaffected arm on the y-axis or in this
case the dominant arm for the healthy
controls so the small circles is healthy
control performance so they're all down
in the bottom left quadrants that's say
for deceleration time it's less than 400
milliseconds
red icons you see are affected in the uh
affected arm is impaired but not the
unaffected arm and the purple ones are
the ones where they actually show
impairments in both arms uh the impaired
affected and unaffected arm
uh the one on the right is simply
showing the same basic principle except
for this case is for the endpoint errors
so
this is the last part of the talk I want
to try to get into sort of future
directions we want to go but also
um thinking about how to make this
available and translate into more
General capabilities and use by other
researchers and the key thing is trying
to automate it and automate these tasks
and processes so we've put a lot of time
into developing a number of tasks visual
guided reaching we are matching object
hit so a number of different tasks have
automated processing for each of these
tasks to extract a number of different
parameters on for each different
behavior and then the bottom right panel
is this neurological report which
basically gives a readout of how this
subject performed and have it compared
to healthy control performance on
whether they are within the healthy
range expected for that individual or
not in a very simple uh automated way
a key of doing this automation has been
for us to focus on identifying what does
healthy performance look like so we have
put through several hundred subjects in
many of these tasks to look at what the
influence of age sex and handedness is
and getting that information we then
developed regression models to uh
to consider the influence of these
factors so that when we assess a subject
we can say that is their performance
normal or not based on the fact that
they are a 55 year old male
we've also started to expand the number
of tasks the key thing is thinking about
this technology is being able to cover a
broad range of sensory motor and
cognitive processes so right now in a
lot of the research projects we're doing
in Queens University and with clinicians
there as well as collaborations at other
locations such as at University of
Calgary we're now using a package of 10
different tasks that are trying to span
a range of sensory motor and cognitive
processes so in the sensory area we have
the limb matching task we have a kinese
task which is a kinesthetic test to
measure a sense of limotion as well as
the postural perturbations to all give
you different aspects of sensory limb
sensory processing
on the motor side we have the visual
guided reaching ball on bar and the
object hit to give different aspects
about limb Upper Limb motor function and
we have a number of tasks that focus on
cognitive domains including the trail
making we have spatial span object hit
and void which gets at the attention and
inhibition processes as well as a visual
reverse task which from the literature
and other researchers have shown is
basically what you do is if your arm
moves to the right the cursor moves to
the left so you have to learn to reverse
your natural sensory motor action and
that's been shown to be indicative of
mild cognitive impairments so we've
added that as well to the suite and with
all these tasks we are now as many other
groups at other locations are covering a
broad range of using this technology to
uh see
different neurological groups and
whether they what's the phenotypes or
patterns of impairments that can be
observed so we have studies going on
going with Cardiac Arrest cerebellar
dysfunctions CP concussion fetalol call
Spence spectrum disorder and a number of
other areas to see how this technology
might be of value
now one of the problems as we develop
more and more tasks is eventually we're
going to have run into the time problem
a subject with stroke can fatigue easily
so there's only so much time you have to
try to quantify and assess them so we're
starting to think about expert and more
con more sophisticated ways of
collecting uh the data and the idea for
example one of them is to develop a
hierarchy of Behavioral tasks where we
may have them perform a few initial
tasks like say Trail making object hit
and limb matching task
from there be able to use expert systems
that make decisions about from how they
performed in those tasks what are the
best next tasks that they should perform
tasks that we know they will pass based
on what they performed in the initial
task we shouldn't bother or waste time
with instead we should focus where we
think some of the impairments are are
going to be more likely to occur perform
those tasks develop further expert
systems that then can try to link the
functional impairments identifying what
we think this subject's problem for
example is sensory processing and we
think the lesion location is here and
about this size on that note I'm trying
to identify lesion location and size and
you've been collecting a lot of Imaging
data so for many of our subjects we have
MRI images of their lesion size and
location and are now trying to correlate
each of our tasks to the underlying
locations of the lesions
foreign
OTS I think have great potential but
there's many other things that other
Technologies I think are going to have
to be involved and engaged with eye
tracking there's a lot of circuits in
the brain that are used and focused on
ocular motor control and so one thing we
have done is we actually integrate eye
tracking Technologies into the robotic
system so we can start to have look at
how they're using their eyes as you do
upper lip motor tasks we've also whole
body tasks robots are really good for uh
Upper Limb function
but clearly for thinking about a
broad-based approach to quantifying
brain function we will have to use and
measure whole body capabilities and
that's where motion tracking
technologies have moved along quite well
and so they're even getting into
motionless tracking and I see it's got
great value it needs to be integrated so
that you can study uh many of the
degrees of freedom of the limb or lower
limb Locomotion gait balance control so
there's going to be a need for pushing
and using that technology as well as the
Lim robotic technology we've also taken
the robotic technology and modified it
so that it can go up and down and now we
can study postural control have Force
plates measure their postural
capabilities while they're performing
the various voluntary tasks we do to
look at a much more broader motor
circuits when they're performing these
tasks on various tasks
now I focused on trying to look at
robots and using them to quantify
impairments and in many ways ways I
would say what we're trying to develop
is the gold standard the costs are very
high
they on the one side but they're also
capable of giving a very comprehensive
uh assessment because we can not only
measure the movements but we can apply
loads and that gives us a lot more
capabilities to assess things there are
people looking at using Gaming
Technologies computers phones even to
get information about the capabilities
and the neurological impairments and I
think there's actually a good role for
those they give less information but the
costs are clearly far lower and
therefore I see in the hopeful and long
term is that there's actually going to
be a hierarchy of technologies that
probably will work together initials
assessments can start with phones
computers to give low cast information
if their problems are identified then
people can move through into the more
sophisticated analysis these techniques
such as what we're trying to develop
with robots
and the last point I wanted to make is
cost and so uh
these are not cheap Technologies there's
no doubt but the fact is many other
Technologies uh clearly have a huge
profound impact Imaging Technologies of
course have huge capabilities to provide
lots of information on the structure of
the brain and other organs they are very
very expensive Technologies but they are
have their value because of what they
can do if robots are going to move into
the Healthcare System clearly there is a
strong need that we have to demonstrate
that there is real value for this type
of assessment and that will take a lot
more research to identify impairments
and how that actually is going to guide
patient care in the future
so for an overview I've tried to talk
about
uh potential robotics for neurological
assessment and I tried to go through a
number of different tasks
visual guided reaching limb matching and
a few other tasks to look at what I
think is the potential of using this
technology for clinical assessment and
then I tried to go through some of the
future directions
um last slide is to acknowledge the many
people that have been involved in this
from my research lab many of the
technicians that have involved in the
development of the technology as well as
some of the grad students Mustafa
mostafavi he was involved in the data
mining Technologies and several others
that were involved in quantifying the
impairments another key colleague is
Sean duclow at The honchkiss Institute
where a lot of our clinical data was
collected last thing I forgot to mention
the beginning of course please submit
questions and I will be able to answer
them right now
so thank you for your time
so I'll go to the questions and answers
so the one question I have sitting here
is many older subjects are rather
machine phobic to begin with do many
subjects impaired or not exhibit stress
or resistance related to the testing
environment that's a really good
question because we were quite worried
about that in fact the other one we were
quite worried about is anyone that would
be claustrophobic because you have to as
you saw in the video you you sort of get
brought into this machine
and the answer
seems to be not it doesn't seem to be a
big problem for us we have put in a lot
of subjects all the way up well into
their 80s and we've had very few that
have had problems so that doesn't seem
to be as much of a problem as initially
I think out of about a thousand subjects
we've probably gone through I know of
one subject that got claustrophobic and
had to come out but other than that it
hasn't been a major problem and most
people when they do the task
um I suspect there's a bit of stress
when they begin but they find note that
it's fairly easy they still can move in
the environment and so they tend to
enjoy their time particularly the tasks
where they get to hit the objects most
people seem to like those tasks because
they're fun to do and fun to play with
robots
foreign
so that's the one question if there's
any other ones I can certainly ask or
respond if anyone has any more
if not then I would like to thank you
all for joining uh to this session and
listening to uh the talk the last thing
I'd like to mention is the for CME
credits uh that you need to go to the
website listed below for you to be able
to get those uh educational credits so
thank you very much for your time
oh should I repeat again
uh could I repeat again about the CME
credits I will assume if not please send
again so if you want to get CME credits
then you need to go to the website
listed on the
um uh slide that is presented right now
on the screen
I have another
foreign